The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
As I was standing here wondering
how to begin today's lesson,
an old story came to mind, of
the professor who passed out
an examination to his class,
and one of the students
said, "Professor,
this is the same test
you gave us last week".
And the professor said,
"I know, but this time I
changed the answers."
And I was thinking of
this in terms of the fact
that much of the new
mathematics is essentially
the old mathematics with
some of the answers changed.
One of the topics that
we used to belittle
in the traditional curriculum,
because it was too easy,
was the topic called
linear equations.
And it turns out that in the
study of several variables
in particular-- but it was
already present in calculus
of a single variable--
we very strongly used
the concept of linearity.
I could've called today's lesson
"something old, something new."
Meaning that the old topic
that we were going to revisit
would be that of
linear functions,
and the new topic would
be how it manifests
into the modern
curriculum in the sense
that one introduces
a subject called
linear algebra,
or matrix algebra,
as a standard portion of
a modern calculus course,
whereas in the traditional
calculus courses,
essentially nothing was ever
said about matrix algebra
or linearity.
Instead I picked a
more conservative title
for today's lesson, I simply
call it "Linearity Revisited".
And as I say, it
goes back to when
we were in junior high
school or high school,
when we were taught that linear
functions were very nice.
For example, given the
equation y equals m*x plus b--
the linear equation
meaning what?
It graphs as a straight line,
but that the two variables
are related linearly, y
is a constant multiple
of x, plus a constant.
We were told solve
for x in terms of y.
And what we found was that
if y equals m*x plus b,
this was true if and only if x
was equal to y minus b over m.
What we showed was
given a value of x,
there corresponded a value
of y, and conversely,
given a value for y, there
corresponded a unique value
for x.
And to put this into the
language of functions,
what we were saying was that
if f of x equals m*x plus b,
then f inverse exists.
In other words, what we're
saying is that no two different
x values can give
you the same y value,
if the function has the
form y equals m*x plus b.
And just about the time
that we were learning
to enjoy this kind
of an equation
our dream world was shattered,
and we were told it's too bad,
but most functions
aren't linear.
We were given things like
y equals x to the seventh
plus x to the
fifth, and we found
that we couldn't solve
for x very conveniently
in terms of y.
And that's what began
our intermediate algebra
and advanced algebra courses.
In other words, the fact that
most functions are non-linear.
Now an interesting
thing occurred though.
Let me just emphasize this.
And this is the key point.
In terms of calculus,
we discovered--
and here's a key word
coming up-- Most functions
are locally linear.
Now that sounds a little
bit like a tongue twister,
but actually back in
the first part of course
when we talked about delta
y sub tan-- a change in y
to the tangent line.
Notice what we were saying.
We were saying that to study
f of x near f equals a,
we saw that f of a plus
delta x minus f of a
was equal to f prime of a
times delta x plus k delta
x, where the limit of
k, as delta x went to 0,
was 0 itself.
Provided of course that f was
differentiable at x equals a;
otherwise, you couldn't
write down f prime of a here.
The interesting point is this.
But if you look just
at this term over here,
this expresses delta f as a
linear function of delta x.
The part that makes this
thing non-linear is the term
called k delta x.
But that's the term
that's going to 0
as a second-order infinitesimal.
So what we're really
saying is this:
that provided that f
is differentiable at x
equals a-- in other words
locally we mean this:
near x equals a, we can say
that delta f is approximately
f prime of a times delta x.
That's what we call
delta f sub tan, recall.
And what we mean by
approximately here
is that error k delta
x goes to 0 very,
very rapidly as
delta x goes to 0.
And what we mean by
locally is this-- suppose
f prime exists also
when x equals b.
We can again compute delta f
near x equals b Now delta f
is equal to what?
Approximately f prime
of b times delta
x plus that error term which
goes to 0 very rapidly.
We again call this
thing here delta f tan,
but the thing to keep in mind
is since f prime of a need
not equal f prime of b, delta f
tan is different at a and at b.
In other words, even
though it's always true
where f is
differentiable, that we
can say that delta f is
approximately delta f tan,
the value of delta f
tan depends on the value
of x that we're near.
And that's what
we mean by saying
that approximating
delta f by delta f
tan is a local property.
Now I think that sometimes,
by putting these things
into words, it sounds
harder than it really is.
So I think what might
be nice is if we just
look at a specific illustration,
a problem which I deliberately
picked to be as simple a
non-linear example as I
can think of.
Let me come back
to our old friend,
the function f of x equals
x squared, which as I say,
is about as simple a non-linear
function we can get into.
Now we know that f of x equals
x squared plots as the curve y
equals x squared, the parabola.
Let's take a couple of
points on this parabola.
Let's say the point 1 comma
1 and the point 2 comma 4.
Draw in the tangent lines to
the curve at these two points.
And we know what?
That the equation of the tangent
line to the curve at (1, 1)
is y minus 1 over x
minus 1 equals the slope.
Since y is equal to x squared,
the slope is 2x; when x is 1
the slope is 2.
So the equation of this tangent
line is given by y minus 1
over x minus 1 equals 2.
At the point corresponding
to x equals 2,
2x is 4, so the equation of the
tangent line here is y minus 4
over x minus 2 equals 4.
So now I've induced
three functions
that I can talk about.
My original function,
f of x is x squared.
This straight line is the
linear function-- just solving
for y in terms of x-- g
of x equals 4x minus 4.
And this straight line
corresponds to the function h
of x equals 2x minus 1.
Now the interesting
point, of course,
is that these two
functions here are linear.
They are completely
different functions.
Notice not only pictorially
are they different,
but algebraically their
slopes are different,
and their y-intercepts
are different,
and back in our
course in part one,
we talked about things
geometrically saying,
lookit, near the
point of tangency,
the tangent line serves
as a good approximation
to the curve itself.
What were we really saying then?
What we were saying was that
near the point of tangency,
g of x, which was
a linear function,
could replace f of x, which
was a non-linear function.
Of course, when we
moved too far away
from a given point, then when
we said that f of x still
had a linear
approximation, we had
to pick a different
linear function.
By the way, again
because we were
dealing with one
independent variable and one
dependent variable, it
was very easy to invent
the concept of a graph.
As we shall show in a little
while, the concept of linearity
extends to several
variables, but you
can't draw the graph as nicely.
So let me now revisit the
same result here, only
without reference to the graph.
What we're saying
is that our function
is mapping the real number
line into the real number line.
In other words, instead of
putting x and y at right
angles to each other, let's put
x and y horizontally parallel
to one another.
And what we're saying is that
f maps the interval from 0 to 2
onto the interval from 0 to 4.
Now what does h do?
Remember h is the
function 2x minus 1.
h maps the interval from
0 to 2 onto the interval
from minus 1 to 3.
And you see this is all this
diagram means. f maps 0 into 0,
it maps 1 into 1, it
maps 2 into 4, et cetera.
In other words, f is the
function which squares
the input to yield the output.
And correspondingly, h maps 0
into minus 1, it maps 1 into 1,
and it maps 2 into 3.
Now the interesting
point is that f and h
are very different.
In fact, the only time f
and h have the same output
is when x equals 1.
Which, of course,
we knew from before,
because how was h
of x constructed?
h of x was constructed to be the
line tangent to the parabola y
equals x squared at the
point x equals 1, y equals 1.
So that should be
no great surprise.
But if we didn't know that,
notice that algebraically, we
could equate f of x to h
of x, conclude, therefore,
that that means x squared
must equal 2x minus 1.
We then transpose, and get that
x minus 1 squared must be 0,
whence x must equal 1.
And what we have is
that near x equals 1,
x squared behaves like-- and
I put this in quotation marks,
because that's the hardest
part of the course that's
going to follow, was what do
you mean by behaves like-- but x
squared behaves like 2x minus 1.
And what we mean by
that is this, at least
in terms of a picture.
If I pick a small
interval surrounding
x equals 1 on the x-axis,
and a small interval--
like a thick dot-- surrounding
y equals 1 on the y-axis here.
Then, as a mapping from
this domain into this range,
I can essentially not
distinguish f from h.
The error is so small that
as the size of the interval
shrinks, the error
goes to 0 even faster.
And therefore, if I stay
close enough, locally,
to the point in question-- if
I stay close enough to this
point, I cannot tell
the difference between
the non-linear function
and the linear function.
But what I have to be
careful about is this--
that whereas x squared can
be replaced by 2x minus 1
near x equals 1,
near x equals 2,
x squared can be replaced again
by a linear function, namely
4x minus 4.
But 4x minus 4 is
not approximately
the same as 2x minus 1,
no matter where you look.
You might say well, lookit,
don't these two straight lines
intersect at the
particular point?
The answer is yes they do.
But even at the point
that they intersect,
there was no
neighborhood in which
these lines can serve as
approximations for one another.
Those are two
straight lines that
intersect at a constant
angle, and as soon
as you leave the
point of intersection
there is a significant error.
Meaning an error which
does not go to 0 more
rapidly than the change in x.
You don't have that higher-order
infinitesimal over here.
At any rate, leaving
this to the exercises
and the supplementary notes,
for you to get more out of,
in summary, let's just say
this: if f is continuously
differentiable at x equals a,
then locally-- meaning near x
equals a-- f behaves linearly.
In other words,
f of x is approximately f
of a plus f prime of a times
the quantity x minus a, and you
see, once x is chosen to be a,
this is a number,
delta x here is
the only variable
on the right-hand side.
So what we're saying is
that f of x is a what?
Linear function of delta x.
And the more
interesting point is--
since this is all review,
so I say-- what I mean
by interesting point is what?
That we don't have to
just review this way,
we did this simply to
refresh your memories
as to how linearity was
playing a big role in calculus
of a single variable.
Now what we're going to
do is extend the result
to several variables.
Let me just say
that at the outset.
That this concept does
extend to n variables,
but n equals 2 yields
a particularly good
geometric insight.
For example, let's suppose I
look at two equations and two
unknowns.
Well actually, I'll
use u and v instead.
Let those be variables.
Also, we can think of
this as a function.
I have u of x, y is x
squared minus y squared,
whereas v of x, y is 2x*y.
Notice that these
are not linear,
because here we have
things appearing
to second power, squares,
and here we have what?
The variables
multiplying one another.
These are not linear equations,
but the beautiful point
is-- if you look at this way--
is even without a picture,
I can think of this
as a mapping which
maps two-dimensional space
into two-dimensional space.
And how does this
mapping take place?
It maps the point or the
pair, or the 2-tuple--
whichever way you
want to say it--
x comma y into the
2-tuple u comma v,
where u is x squared minus
y squared, and v is 2x*y.
In other words,
f-bar-- and notice I
put the bar underneath,
simply to indicate that
E^2 is a vector space,
and we have a function
that's mapping what?
A vector into a vector, so I
indicate that f is a vector
function here.
It maps a vector into a vector.
And how does the
mapping take place?
It maps the 2-tuple x comma
y into the 2-tuple x squared
minus y squared comma 2x*y.
(u, v).
Now, the thing is that as long
as we only have n equals 2,
we can still draw a picture, but
not a picture as nice as what
existed when n was equal to 1.
See, pictorially,
f-bar maps the xy-plane
into what we can
call the uv-plane.
But notice that since
the domain of f-bar
has two degrees of freedom-- a
two-dimensional vector space--
notice that the domain of
f-bar is the entire xy-plane,
whereas the range of f-bar
is the entire uv-plane.
In other words, I
can now view f-bar
as a mapping which carries
points in the xy-plane
into points in the uv-plane.
And this will be exploited
more later in the course,
but the idea is this.
Let's take a look
for the time being.
Let's see what f-bar does
to the point 2 comma 1.
Remember u is x squared
minus y squared,
so at the point 2 comma
1, u becomes what?
2 squared minus 1
squared, which is 3.
On the other hand, 2x*y is 2
times 2 times 1, which is 4.
So f-bar can be viewed as
mapping the point 2 comma
1 into the point 3 comma 4.
Now you recall
that calculus isn't
interested in what's happening
at a particular point.
It's interested in what's
happening in the neighborhood
of a particular point.
So the major question
is, how does f-bar behave
near the point 2 comma 1.
In other words,
what is f-bar of 2
plus delta x comma 1 plus delta
y, when delta x and delta y are
quite small.
That's the question that
we're raising over here.
What we're saying is, we know
that 2 comma 1 maps into 3
comma 4.
We also know or we'd like to
believe that a point near 2
comma 1 maps into a
point near 3 comma 4.
Well if we call
this point 2 plus
delta x comma 1
plus delta y, then
the corresponding
image over here
should be 3 plus delta
u comma 4 plus delta v.
What we can say is that
whatever the image of 2
plus delta x comma
1 plus delta y
is, it has the form 3 plus
delta u comma 4 plus delta v,
and all we have to do is find
delta u and delta v. This
is the pictorial idea
of what's happening.
Now the point is that
delta u and delta
v are very difficult to find.
After all, u and v are
non-linear functions.
To invert them is
either difficult,
or downright impossible, one
or the other, in many cases.
The thing that's easy to find
is delta u tan, and delta v tan.
Remember delta u tan was the
partial of u with respect to x
times delta x, plus the
partial of u with respect to y
times delta y.
Since u is equal to x
squared minus y squared,
that means delta u tan is
2x delta x minus 2y delta y.
We're interested in this
at the point 2 comma 1.
Letting x be 2, and y be
1, we see that delta u tan
is 4 delta x minus 2 delta y.
Similarly, since v
is equal to 2x*y,
the partial of v with
respect to x is 2y;
the partial with v with
respect to y is 2x.
Therefore, delta v sub tan is
2y delta x plus 2x delta y.
Since we're evaluating
this at x equals 2,
y equals 1, we see that delta v
tan is two delta x plus 4 delta
y.
Now here's the key point.
This is always delta u tan.
This is always delta v tan.
Where the local
thing comes in is
that we know that because
u and v are continuously
differentiable functions of x
and y, that near the point 2
comma 1, we can replace delta
u by delta u sub tan, delta v
by delta v sub tan, and
we wind up with what?
delta u is approximately
4 delta x minus 2 delta y.
delta v is approximately
2 delta x plus 4 delta y.
But the key point
now is that this is
a system of linear equations.
You see, delta u is
a linear combination
of delta x and
delta y, and delta v
is also a linear combination
of delta x and delta y.
In other words,
as long as u and v
are continuously differentiable
functions of x and y,
we can approximate,
locally, delta u and delta
v by linear approximations.
Notice how linear
systems come into play.
Now I've been emphasizing
the case n equals 2 just
so we could draw a picture.
Notice that no matter how
many variables we have-- well,
in fact, let me just summarize
this in terms of x and y first.
And then we'll generalize it
to n variables in a minute.
The key point for two
variables, and what
happens for two variables
happens for any number.
But as we've often
done in this course,
we emphasize the
two-variable case
because we can still
visualize the picture.
Even though the graph
idea is hard to see,
because we're mapping two
dimensions into two dimensions.
But at least the
domain and the range
are easy to see
separately, but if u
is a continuously
differentiable function
of x and y near the
point (x_0, y_0),
then delta u is exactly the
partial of u with respect to x
times delta x, plus the partial
of u with respect to y times
delta y, plus an error term,
k_1 delta x plus k_2 delta y,
where k_1 and k_2 go to 0, as
delta x and delta y go to 0.
In other words,
if we just look at
this part alone,
delta u is linear up to
this as a correction term.
In other words, the
non-linearity part of delta u
is going to 0 as a
second-order infinitesimal,
and the reason I keep
harping on this point
is that no matter how
complex the theory gets,
in the rest of this
particular block,
the key step is
always going to be
that when you have
a continuously
differentiable function you
can essentially-- as long you
stay locally-- you
can essentially
throw away the nasty part.
You can essentially throw
away this error term,
because it goes to 0 so
rapidly that if you stay close
enough to the point
x_0, y_0, no harm comes
from neglecting this term.
What you must be
careful about is
that as soon as you pick a
large enough neighborhood so
that this term is no
longer negligible, then
even though this part here
is still delta u sub tan,
delta u sub tan is no longer a
good approximation for delta u.
At any rate, in n variables,
what we're saying is,
suppose w is a function
of x_1 up to x_n.
Then if w happens
to be continuously
differentiable at the
point corresponding
to x-bar equals a-bar--
meaning, in terms of n-tuples,
x_1 up to x_n is the
point a_1 comma up
to a_n-- then what we're saying
is that delta w can be replaced
by-- now this has been
mentioned the text,
I don't remember whether
we've mentioned this
in previous lectures or not.
It's rather
interesting that when
you deal with more than three
independent variables we
somehow don't like to use
the word delta w sub tan.
Because tangent indicates a
tangent line or a tangent plane
which is a geometric concept.
Instead we replace the
word tangent by L-I-N
as an abbreviation for linear.
The key point being what?
That this thing that we
call delta w sub lin,
or if you like to call it
sub tan, what's in a name?
Call it whatever you want.
The point is that this thing
that we call delta w sub
lin or delta w sub tan is
the partial of f with respect
to x_1 evaluated at
a-bar times delta x1,
plus the partial
of f with respect
to x sub n evaluated at
a-bar times delta x_n.
And the key point
is that once you
have chosen a
specific number a-bar,
notice that the coefficients
of delta x_1 up to delta x_n
are numbers.
They're not variables.
They are numbers
once a is chosen.
So that what is delta w lin,
why do we call it linear?
Notice that this expression
here is a linear combination
of delta x_1 up to delta x_n.
In other words they're what?
Sums of terms each involving
a delta x times-- excuse me.
A delta x times a constant.
What we're saying is
that nice functions,
and what's a nice function?
A nice function is one which
is continuously differentiable.
A nice function
is locally linear.
In other words, a continuously
differentiable function,
near a particular point,
can be approximated
by a linear function,
where the error will
be very small as
long as you stay
near the point in question.
You remember, at the
beginning of my lecture,
I said something
old, something new.
This finishes the old
part of the course.
In other words, what I've
tried to motivate for you here
is why, if we were remodeling
the pre-calculus curriculum,
much more emphasis should
be paid to linear equations.
Granted that most functions
in real life are non-linear,
the point remains that
locally, functions are linear.
OK?
That's the key point.
Locally we deal with
linear functions.
Therefore, since all
non-linear functions
may be viewed as
being linear locally,
this motivates why we
should really study
systems of linear equations.
In other words, this
motivates the subject
called linear systems.
Now what is a linear system?
Essentially, a linear system
is m equations in n unknowns.
In many cases m and n
are taken to be equal,
but what kind of
equations are they?
They are equations where all
the variables appear separately
to the first power multiplied
only by a constant term,
and by the way, let me
introduce this double subscript
notation rather than introducing
umpteen different symbols
for constants.
Notice that a very
nice device here
is to pick one symbol, like an
a, and then use two subscripts.
The first subscript
telling you what row
the coefficient is referring
to, and the second one
which column.
Or in terms of the equations,
the first subscript
tells you which equation
you're dealing with,
and the second
subscript tells you
what variable it's multiplying.
For example this is what?
This is the coefficient of x
sub 1 in the first equation.
sub n in the first equation.
This is the coefficient of x
sub n in the n-th equation.
Think of this as the row
and the column if you will.
And what we're saying then is
that the solutions of this type
of system of equations
are really controlled
by the coefficients of the x's.
In other words, by
the numbers a sub ij,
where i and j can take on--
well i takes on all values
from what?
The number of rows. i goes from
1 to m, and j goes from 1 to n.
But the a's become
very important,
and this is what
ultimately is going
to motivate what we
mean by a matrix,
but before I come to that,
let me give you just one
example of what I mean by saying
that the equations are governed
by the coefficients of the
x's, not by the constants
on the right-hand side.
By the way, notice
the convention
that when you have two
equations with two unknowns,
rather than call the
unknowns x_1 and x_2,
it's conventional to call
the unknowns x and y.
Let's take a particularly
simple system here-- x plus y
equals b_1, x
minus y equals b_2.
If we add these
two equations, we
get 2x is b_1 plus
b_2, whereupon
x is b_1 plus b_2 over 2.
If we subtract
the two equations,
we get 2y is b_1
minus b_2, whereupon y
is b_1 minus b_2 over 2.
Notice that this tells us
how to solve for x and y
in terms of b_1 and b_2.
Namely, to find x you take
half the sum of the two b's.
To find y, you take
half the difference.
Now certainly, the
solution depends
on the values of b_1 and b_2.
I'm not saying you don't
change the answers by changing
the constants on this side.
What I am saying is that
the structure by which you
find the answers does not
depend on b_1 and b_2;
it's determined solely by
the coefficients of x and y.
What we're saying
is, no matter what
b_1 and b_2 are in this
particular problem,
to find x and y we take half
the sum of the b's, and we
take half the difference.
In other words, the
solution depends
on b_1 and b_2 numerically,
but not structurally.
Well, the whole idea is
this-- and this is what
we so often do in mathematics.
Because the solution
to our equations
depends on the coefficients
of the x's, we somehow
want to focus our attention
on the coefficients.
And we don't need
the x's in there,
because we can sort of think of
the x's as being a place value
type of situation.
In other words,
x_1 can be thought
of as being the first column.
x_2 the second column.
The first equation can be
thought of as the first row.
The second equation,
the second row.
And what this
motivates is a concept
called an m by n matrix.
Now this sounds like a very
ominous term, an m by n matrix.
But the point is it's
not a very ominous term.
It's in fact, I think
that it's too-- in fact
the word matrix essentially
indicates an array,
and that's all this thing is.
By an m by n matrix, we simply
mean a rectangular array
of numbers, arranged
to form m rows--
In other words,
the first number tells
you the number of rows,
and the second number tells
you the number of columns.
Now there's certainly
nothing logical about that
in terms of our game idea.
Just memorize this, it's a rule
of the game or a definition.
Somebody could've
said, why didn't you
give the columns first
and then the rows?
Well we could've, but one
of them had to come first.
And the convention is that
one refers to the rows
first, and then the columns.
An m by n matrix then is what?
It's a rectangular array
of numbers consisting
of m rows and n columns.
By way of an example-- by the
way, to indicate that's you're
talking about a
matrix, one usually
encloses the array in
brackets, or in parentheses.
It doesn't make any difference.
I will use whichever one
strikes my fancy at the moment.
And it happens to be
brackets right now.
But if I write down this
array-- what is it now?
[1, 1, 1; 1, -1, 2].
This is a rectangular array
of numbers consisting of what?
Two rows and three columns.
And so this is an example
of a 2 by 3 matrix.
A 2 by 3 matrix.
Now again, we don't want to
invent this thing vacuously.
Let's keep track of
what this matrix is
coding for us in terms
of a system of equations.
Well.
For example, suppose we have
the system of equations z_1
is equal to y_1
plus y_2 plus y_3.
z_2 is equal to y_1
minus y_2 plus 2*y_3,
and we want to think
of the y_1, y_2,
and y_3 as being the
variables, z_1 and z_2 as being
the constants here.
What is the matrix
of coefficients here?
Well the matrix would be what?
The coefficient of the first
variable in the first column
is 1; second variable,
first column is 1;
third variable, first row is 1.
You see?
Second equation, first
variable coefficient
is 1; second equation,
second variable coefficient
is minus 1;
second equation, third
variable coefficient is 2.
So using our matrix
coding system,
the matrix of coefficients
would be what?
[1, 1, 1; 1, -1, 2].
Which is exactly the matrix
that we wrote down over here.
And to put this into a
different perspective,
so to see what we're driving
at, let's take a second example
where we first start out
with three equations and four
unknowns.
Three linear equations
and four unknowns.
And then we'll write the
matrix for this afterwards.
But let the equations be y sub 1
is x_1 plus 2*x_2 plus x_3 plus
x_4.
y_2 is 2*x_1 minus x_2
minus x_3 plus 3*x_4.
y_3 is 3*x_1 plus x_2
plus 2*x_3 minus x_4.
if I want to write the matrix
of coefficients, what do I do?
I simply leave the variables
out, and write down what?
My first row would be what?
[1, 2, 1, 1].
My second row would
be [2, -1,  -1, 3].
My third row would
be [3, 1, 2,  -1].
In other words, my
matrix of coefficients,
now, would be what
kind of a matrix?
It would be a rectangular
array of numbers,
consisting of three
rows and four . columns.
All right?
And that would be
called a 3 by 4 matrix.
Again, notice, in this coding
system, the number of rows
corresponds to the
number of equations.
And the number of
columns corresponds
to the number of
variables that are
formed in linear combinations.
To summarize this
again, the matrix
of coefficients in
our second example
is the 3 by 4 matrix [1, 2, 1,
1; 2, -1, -1, 3; 3, 1, 2, -1].
Well again, let's recall
that when we do mathematics,
we don't like to
introduce notation
for the sake of notation.
And simply to be able to have
a way of conveniently writing
the coefficients, but
not being able to use it
efficiently would be a
rather stupid thing to do.
Why invent new notation
if it's not going to help
us effectively
solve new problems?
This is why in mathematics
we've been emphasizing
the game idea, whereby what we
really care about is structure.
We care about structure, not
about the terms themselves.
And to motivate
what I'm driving at,
let me return to
examples one and two.
And bring up a question
that has great impact--
and even if we don't
appreciate it right now
in terms of a
practical application,
let's at least see
what's happening.
You'll notice that if I look
at these systems of equations
over here, notice that the
first two equations tell me
how to express z_1 and z_2 in
terms of y_1, y_2, and y_3.
On the other hand, the
second system of equations
tells me how to express
y_1, y_2, and y_3 in terms
of x_1, x_2, x_3, and x_4.
Now, without
belaboring the point
because the arithmetic
is quite trivial here,
a very natural question
that might come up next this
is, lookit, let's look at
our old friend the chain
rule again.
Since the z's are
expressed in terms
of the y's, and the y's
are expressed in terms
of the x's, it seems that
by direct substitution,
I should be able to express
the z's in terms of the x's.
Namely, I replace y_1 by this
linear combination of the x's.
I replace y_2 by this linear
combination of the x's.
I replace y_3 by this linear
| then combine the y's in terms
of the x's as indicated here.
And that should give me the
z's in terms of the x's.
Leaving that, hopefully,
as a trivial exercise,
we come to the next example
that I'd like to mention here,
and that is: suppose
you were told
to express z_1 and z_2 in
terms of x_1, x_2, x_3 and x_4.
The point is that, with the
amount of arithmetic mentioned
before, we could easily show
that z_1 was 6*x_1 plus 2*x_2
plus 2*x_3 plus 3*x_4,
while z_2 was 5*x_1 plus
5*x_2 plus 6*x_3 minus 4*x_4,
by a straightforward
substitution.
The point is that
somehow or other,
we would like to be able to
handle this substitution more
efficiently.
Is there a neater way of
being able to transform
the z's into the x's
by way of the y's?
In other words, is there
a way of replacing the y's
by the x's, and then
finding z's in terms
of x's in a convenient,
mechanical way that
will save us much steps?
Not so much in these easy
examples where you have 2 by 3,
and 3 by 4 systems, but
cases where you might have
10 equations and 10 unknowns.
Or 10 equations and 12 unknowns.
And the answer is,
there is a way.
Of course, you knew there
was going to be a way.
Otherwise we wouldn't
be leading up to it
in this particular way,
and as so often happens,
there usually happens to be
a real-life situation that
motivates why we
invent something
called matrix algebra.
In terms of our
present illustration,
the chain rule that
we're just talking
about expressing the z's in
terms of the y's, and then
the y's in terms of
the x's motivates
what we mean by
matrix multiplication.
And you may notice that I
put "multiplication" here
in quotation marks.
The reason I put
in quotation marks
is that unfortunately
the word "multiplication"
has a connotation of
multiplying numbers together.
Don't think of it that way.
Think of multiplication
meaning what?
A way of combining two matrices
to form another matrix.
There's going to be no logic
behind this other than one
very famous piece of logic.
That is knowing what the
answer was supposed to be,
we make up our rules
to guarantee us
that we will get the
appropriate answer.
In other words,
I remember when I was an
undergraduate in college.
The big type of humor that
was going around at that time
was the idea of, somebody
would give you the answer,
and you have to make
up the question.
Oh, they were silly
little things like,
if the answer to the question
was 9w what was the question?
And the question
would be, do you
spell your last name with a
V, Herr Wagner, and the answer
would be "nein, W."
And these were funny
jokes at that time.
I don't know whether
they're funny now or not.
But the funny point is this.
That this joke, which
might not be that funny,
is exactly how we motivate
definitions and rules
in mathematics.
We start with the
answer, and then
go back, and answer
the question.
Knowing in advance
that somehow or other,
the matrix that
expresses the z's
in terms of the y's
is given by this.
And the matrix that expresses
the y's in terms of the x's, is
given by this matrix.
Somehow or other what
we would like to do
is invent a way of combining
these two matrices to give me
the matrix that
expresses this answer.
In other words, if I start
knowing what the answer is
supposed to be-- in other
words, what is the matrix that
expresses the z's
in terms of the x's?
It's the matrix whose
first row is [6, 2, 2, 3].
And whose second row
is [5, 5,  6, -4].
In other words, the
matrix would be what?
[6, 2, 2, 3; 5, 5, 6, -4].
And without even looking
at any mechanical rule,
the question that
comes up is, how can I
invent a rule that
will tell me how
to multiply this 2 by 3
matrix by this 3 by 4 matrix
to obtain this 2 by 4 matrix?
2 by 4 matrix.
Now lookit.
In the notes, I'm going to
do this in great detail.
There will be many
exercises on this for you
to sharpen your teeth on.
But for now I just want
to hit this main point,
because the lecture
is quite long.
Your attention span probably
is starting to be taxed.
And so I just want to show
you what the recipe is,
because my feeling is
that this is something
you have to hear before you can
really read it without becoming
panicked by the notation.
The idea is this: first of
all, to multiply two matrices,
all we ever require is
that the number of columns
in the first matrix
equals the number of rows
in the second matrix.
And if that sounds
complicated to you,
simply think in terms
of the chain rule again.
The number of columns
in the first matrix
tells you how many
unknowns there
are in the first
system of equations.
And that number of
unknowns gives you
the number of equations
in the second system.
In other words, the number of
columns in the first matrix
must match the number of
rows in the second matrix.
Notice, we don't care
about the number of rows
in the first one matching
the number of columns
in the second, all we care
is that the number of columns
in the first matrix--
namely three here-- match
the number of rows of the
second, which is three.
Then the rule works in a very
interesting mechanical way that
makes use of the dot product.
Namely, what you
do is, suppose I
want to find the term in the
product of these two matrices
that occupies the second
row, third column.
What I do is I take the
second row-- in other words,
I take the row comes
from the first matrix.
I take the column value
from the second matrix.
In other words, I have what?
Second row, third column.
And I form the usual dot
product that we've talked about.
I dot the second row
with the third column.
And what would I
get if I did that?
1 times 1 is 1; minus 1 times
minus 1 is 1; and 2 times 2
is 4.
So 1 plus 1 plus 4 is 6.
So in this product
matrix, the term
in the second row,
third column will be 6.
The term in the second row,
Second row, third
column will be 6.
Now, leaving it as an
exercise for the time being,
and reading it in the
supplementary notes,
I'm sure you'll be able
to put this all together.
It's not nearly as
difficult as it sounds
hearing it the first time.
I think the most difficult
part is rationalizing
why one would invent such a
definition in the first place.
The answer is very simple:
we invent the definition
to solve a particular problem.
Coming back here
again, all I'm saying
is that if I
invent-- for example,
let me just give you one
more checking-out point here.
Let me see what
the term would be
in the first row, second column.
To find the term in the
first row, second column,
I take the first row
of the first matrix.
Dot it with the second
column of the second matrix.
See first row dotted
with second column,
the answer will give me what?
The term in the product
that's in the first row,
second column.
Let's check that.
1 times 2 is 2; 1 times minus
1 is minus 1; 1 times 1 is 1.
2 minus 1 plus 1 is 2.
And therefore, the term in
the first row, second column
should be 2.
It is.
You see, there's
no more motivation
to how we multiply these
two matrices than the fact
that it solves the problem
that we want solved.
To find the term
that's in the i-th row,
j-th column of the
product, dot the i-th row
of the first matrix
with the j-th column
of the second matrix.
More generally, you can always
multiply an m by n matrix
by an n by p matrix.
What's the key factor?
You don't care about the
number of rows in the first,
you don't care about the number
of columns in the second.
What you do care about is what?
That the number of columns
in the first matrix
be equal to the number
of rows in the second,
and if you do that, when you
multiply an m by n matrix
by an n by p matrix, notice
that the result will be what?
An m by p matrix.
In other words,
the number of rows
is governed by the number
of rows in the first matrix
and a number of
columns is governed
by the number of columns
in the second matrix.
Notice, by the way,
that this tells us
right away that when we want
to multiply two matrices
it makes a difference in which
order that they're written.
If we were to take that 2 by 3
matrix, and the 3 by 4 matrix,
and interchange them, we don't
have the appropriate match
up of rows and columns.
You can't dot a
2-tuple with a 4-tuple.
The very fact that we say
dot the row with the column,
the dot product is only
defined for two n-tuples.
We insist that the
n-tuples be the same.
The n has to be the same
to dot two n-tuples.
Let me summarize today's
lecture by saying
that in overview, notice
that what we've done,
hopefully, is that
we have reestablished
the need for linear
systems of equations,
and secondly, once we
have understood what
the need for linear systems
is, we are now introducing
a mechanism whereby we can
solve linear systems more
efficiently than what we were
taught in the past as to how
to solve them.
You see, what I'm going to do
for the next few lectures now
is concentrate on
a new game, called
the game of matrix algebra.
But that will unfold gradually
as we develop the next two
lectures.
And so until our next
lecture, so long.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.